The first thing I ask every
storyteller, personal storyteller,
or business is who is the audience?
And about half the time, they
don't know, which is crazy.
You have to know who you're talking to.
You have to know what your
audience is going to be before
you figure out what to say.
One Super Bowl commercial
nailed this perfectly, and
another one failed miserably.
Let's take a look at each one.
The opening Shah is of a flag in
the mountains and the landscapes.
Longest thing we ever
do is live our lives,
but life doesn't come
with an owner's manual.
Harrison Ford.
Harrison Ford is an actor that.
Every single human being likes
he is perfectly universal and
perfect for this commercial.
And notice how as the commercial
opens, you don't quite know who it is.
They open with a side view,
which creates suspense.
Who is it?
And then you hear the voice
first and you think lives.
I know that voice.
But life doesn't come with a
normal.
And then he turns, turns and you see who
it is, and you feel like you're at home.
It's Harrison Ford.
Everything he says, I will believe
might've been nice, huh?
But that means we get to
write our own stories.
Freedom is yes or no, or maybe.
That's all of the commercial right there.
We're gonna be speaking to two different
audiences, essentially, this is a
commercial for two kinds of people.
It is for Jeep owners that wanna
put gasoline in their machines and
drive into the mountains and tear
up the ground and have a great time.
And it's also for Jeep owners.
Who wanna buy an electric
vehicle and quietly drive
down the street to the store.
That is literally what this
commercial is speaking to.
It's speaking to both audiences
simultaneously and they're using Harrison
Ford to say basically, both are fine.
We're all good.
I.
Freedom is for everybody,
but it isn't free.
It's a bond.
So we flashed to some World War
II footage because everyone agrees
that World War II vets are to be
admired and respected at all costs.
There are real heroes.
Note here that a dog appears the
only other character in the story.
We put a dog into the story because
along with the flag and World War II vts.
Dogs are something we agree upon
almost more than we agree upon that.
Harrison Ford is extraordinary.
We throw the dog in because
everyone loves a dog,
but not the ones in the movies.
Real heroes are humble.
They're not driven by pride.
Harrison Ford says that real
heroes are not in the movies.
He's basically saying, I'm not a hero,
which makes us think he's a hero.
And Harrison Ford is making a simple
statement that we all agree to.
Real heroes are not driven by pride.
They're humble, and we get a
flash of another veteran coming
home and hugging his daughter.
Freedom is the roar of one man's,
and now we get two Jeeps.
We get the one without doors that
you drive in the mountains with gas.
Freedom is the ability to inspire,
and we get Harrison Ford driving an
electric vehicle right next to it.
The two of them are equal.
The two of them are fine.
Everyone is good.
You don't have to be friends
with someone to wave at 'em.
at someone to wave at them.
And at that moment, the electric vehicle
and the gas vehicle, they pass each other.
And Harrison Ford is basically
saying it's okay if we disagree.
We can still wave at each other.
We won't always agree on which way to go,
but our differences can be our strength,
our differences can be our strength.
I can buy an electric vehicle,
you can buy a gas powered vehicle,
and that's gonna be our strength.
And the way those two Jeeps pass
each other and the trails form a
V with one going in one direction,
one going the other direction.
But they're all driving,
they're all in a Jeep.
They're thinking entirely about the
audience and speaking to two different
groups of people simultaneously.
And highly, effectively.
So choose but choose wisely.
Choose what makes you happy.
We get the picture of an electric
vehicle being unplugged, which
is great for Jeep, simple to use.
Plug it in, plug it out.
We get an image of a Jeep.
My friends, my family, by work.
Make me happy,
my friends, my family, my work
make me happy first, and then
this Jeep makes me happy.
Jeep is smart.
It's the fourth thing.
It's not the first thing,
even though my name is,
even though my name is
Ford, which is a joke.
And then the only elder character
in the commercial speaks a tiny bit,
which is the dog makes a little wine.
As if to indicate the joke wasn't funny.
That's my owner's manual.
Get out there, write your own.
And at the end of the commercial,
we're right back where it began.
The beginning of the commercial.
Harrison Ford is at a fireplace
saying, wouldn't it be nice
if life had an owner's manual?
And at the end of the commercial
he says, that's my owner's manual.
Get out there.
Write your own.
In other words, buy a Jeep.
This is a commercial that
understands audience and knows
exactly who they're speaking to.
Now I am gonna talk about a commercial
that fails when it comes to audience.
And oddly enough, I am the
audience for this commercial.
I grew up 30 minutes south of Boston.
I am a Patriot season ticket holder.
I watched the Celtics win the championship
in the Fleet center last year.
I am Boston through and through.
So I am the audience for this commercial.
And the problem is.
I am the audience for this commercial.
It's a Super Bowl commercial,
and it's targeting essentially
me and not the country.
The first problem with it before I even
hit start, is the fact that it's a sequel.
It's a sequel to a commercial from
last year, which suffers from the
curse of knowledge because we have
now had 365 days to forget about the
commercial we saw last year, and now
we're picking up where it left off.
This makes no sense whatsoever.
There should not be a sequel in the Super
Bowl commercial unless that commercial
ran ubiquitously, (ubiquitously?),
ubiquitously all year long.
So the sequel is a terrible idea.
Already you're gonna lose half the people
who don't know what the hell is going on.
But let's take a look
at the commercial now.
Welcome to Java Jet Battle
of the Coffee Brand Band.
So we've got a whole bunch of
people who just flashed across
the screen and I'm wondering.
Who are those people and
am I supposed to know them?
But one of the biggest problems
with this commercial is there's
a whole bunch of people in it.
Some of them I recognize, like Ben
Affleck and I kind of recognize
Casey Affleck, but I don't really,
'cause he's got giant glasses on.
So the whole time I'm looking at it and
going, is that Casey Affleck in that
hat and those orange glasses probably.
'cause he's sitting next to Ben and
I know looking at this now that Bill
Belichick is standing behind him and
I know who Bill Belichick is because.
You know, I sat in that stadium for
the last 22 years, and I honor Bill
Belichick and I know who he is, but
boy, I hope other people know who he is.
This is the first problem
with the commercial.
The audience is everywhere, meaning
they're throwing out tons of references,
pop culture, and instead of hoping
to sort of hit somebody with one of
the references, they're confusing me.
I'm wondering who all these people are.
They're thinking, well, he got Belichick.
Isn't he good?
He got Affleck.
No, he's not because he's confused
about all these other people.
Forget them Suckers.
Matt Damon and Tom Brady don't
have the hot of a champion.
We go to News Squad, DunKings
Sequel Affleck's and Belichick.
Dunk King.
DunKings Sequel.
So if you don't remember the commercial
from last year, we have a sequel
and this is the moment where you go.
What do you mean DunkKings Sequel?
A little more spirit on the, uh,
you know, on the charge next time.
Alright.
We got a fourth dunk king too coming.
We have a fourth dunk king coming
identified who this person is by
actually putting their name on
the door that is about to open.
It's Jeremy Strong.
If you have to put someone's name
essentially on them, you are already
worried that people don't know who,
who the hell this guy is, right?
It's Jeremy Strong.
Do you know who Jeremy Strong is?
You might.
You might know who Jeremy Strong is if
you watch DunKings Sequel or maybe one of
his films, but probably DunKings Sequel.
It turns out the DunKings
Sequel was only on HBO max.
So if you didn't own the HBO Max, you
don't know who the hell this guy is.
And I didn't even know
he was related to Boston.
And I am a Boston guy.
This guy does not have a Boston accent.
He has nothing about him that
says Boston to me, but he is
gonna be in this commercial now.
And so.
Jeremy Strong emerges from a vat
of coffee beans, which means if I
don't know who Jeremy Strong is based
upon his name, I'm never gonna see
his face and understand who he is.
If I could see his face,
I'd go, oh, it's that actor.
It's that guy in DunKings Sequel,
or that guy in a movie I saw,
but he's covered in coffee beans.
So if I'm trying to figure out how I know
Jeremy Strong, because I'm a ordinary
American that doesn't watch everything
on television and I don't see every
movie, I have no idea who this guy is.
Oh my God.
Amen.
Is that I'm looking at him now.
He's indiscernible.
You've actually managed to get
Jeremy Strong in your commercial
and make him indiscernible.
This is not understanding your audience.
If you open your commercial, a
one minute commercial with me,
wondering if it's Casey Affleck.
That's what my mind is occupied by, right?
We're distracting the audience by
throwing so many references at them
that they're trying to keep up.
It is cognitively disturbing.
And now we have a guy who we might
know if we could actually see his
face and a vat of coffee beans, but
we don't know who the hell he is.
What are you doing in there?
I'm just trying to find the character.
I'm all in for Dunkin'.
(*click sound).
Now, the one thing I do like
that they do is the opponents
are wearing a green uniform.
They can't put Starbucks
on their commercial or they
get sued to high heaven.
Right?
But they have done a good job of making
it clear that it is Dunkin' versus
Starbucks and living in a town where the
Starbucks and the Dunkin are literally
across the street from each other.
This they have done at least
slightly well, but I'll tell
you as this scene progresses,
Get roasted!
like a dark seasonal roast with
coriander and slight balsamic drizzle.
Sounds like what's in my garbage disposal.
That was the funniest
line in the whole thing.
See you coach.
How much to wait a half hour to get
my name spelled wrong on the cup?
Nobody wants a gold milk.
Double half calf salt milk cap.
You could just brew it.
It's beans and water.
Oh damn.
Listen, Dunkin's for all of you.
That's it.
Duncan is for all of you, that is the
whole point of the commercial, right?
It took him forever to get to the
idea that Dunkin is for all of you,
and the only way they made that
point was essentially Casey Affleck
said, nobody wants your coffee.
It's just beans and water.
Essentially, the whole commercial
comes down to the idea that coffee is
nothing but beans and water, therefore.
You should go to Dunkin' Donuts.
That is it.
They undermine the idea of what coffee
is, beans and water, nothing more.
And therefore, because of that, Dunkin'
Donuts is the best because, because we
have Bill Belichick and Casey Affleck
and Ben Affleck and some people, I still
can't figure out who the hell they are.
That's not a great message.
When your company's message
about the product you make is.
It's kind of nothing.
It's just beans and water.
That doesn't make me think,
well, hell, I gotta go get the
Dunkin' Donuts, beans and water.
They throw a whole bunch of things
on the screen and they hope that
something resonates with you.
Jeep presents a clear, clean, obvious
message from a single spokesperson who
everyone knows and who everyone trusts.
This commercial, this Dunkin
Donuts commercial, it is a mistake.
It fails to take account for audience.
That is the difference between
these two commercials, and that is
what we must do as storytellers.
First and foremost, before you open your
mouth or put your pen to the page or your
fingers to the keys, the first thing you
ask yourself is who is your audience?
And then you craft a message
that that audience will listen
to, believe and understand.
Jeep did it brilliantly.
Dunkin' Donuts failed.